never but you never put the gas back
always pushing over to the brain freeze
never expect your respect
Brutus reach that gives you be straight
[Music]
after falling in love with daredevil no
though they say love is blind Luke Cage
and Jessica Jones I was over the moon to
hear that there was gonna be a defender
series marbles clearly know what they're
doing in terms of team ups and all of
the solo series were hits commercially
and critically what could go wrong well
a lot apparently in Marvel's
worst-performing Netflix show the
defenders clearly didn't live up to the
highs after re-watching the series I'm
here to give my opinion on why the show
underperformed reason 1 the most
interesting character is a mute Elektra
is by far the most interesting character
in the defenders universe after debuting
in daredevil season 2 her embodiment of
the femme fatale made her a joy to watch
she really shook up the show and was one
of the highlights of that season so most
fans were excited to see what she would
bring to this crossover as intelligent
as she is beautiful Elektra is the
perfect and hero she's traveled the
world being CEO of a billion-dollar
corporation learned a plethora of
martial arts styles done a ton of
cocaine stared death in the face and
being resurrected surely there's a lot
sure has to tell us well not really
being the mute for most of the defenders
she pretty much becomes a lap dog the
henchmen who shows up from time to time
just to fight the team get very
repetitive it gets more repetitive than
the phrase around the world in the song
around the world by Daft Punk well she
does eventually get the redemption that
we desperately want for her it's a long
time coming and the weight isn't worth
it Elektra should have been silent for
at most two episodes the fact that it
takes SS before she even begins to the
mold makes it very difficult and become
as invested in the character as we
were sure my granddad thinks women
should be seen and not heard but
everyone else wants to hear what Elektra
has to say so it's a massively missed
opportunity reason for too much bloody
iron fists juxtaposing the most
interesting character we have the least
interesting one iron fist I never really
got the thinking behind putting him in
the lead role I in fist was pan
critically and is one of the worst
performing Netflix shows well ever so
it's baffling that Marvel decided to put
him in the central role where all of the
plot elements relied on him being a
major part of the team the character is
so bland and boring the most intriguing
thing about him his fist gets used about
four times throughout the entire show
and even then it looks like he's just
been eating too many watts it's it's
just so bad
the producers possessing neither the
budget or charisma to truly present him
as a billionaire he basically just ends
up being a guy in a suit have no idea
why was picked as the lead as there are
three more far superior characters in
the team that they could have focused on
reason three too much focus on side
characters when watching a show called
the defenders I want to see the
defenders I'm guessing many fans felt
exactly the same so I have no idea why
we spend so much time with stick
Kaleem wing Karen Paige the radio host
Jessica hangs around with misty and the
rest of the sidekicks we see more of the
police department office than we do the
New York skyline having such a beautiful
city to film in and instead pointing a
camera at a desk so we can see misty
walk around asking questions that we
already know the answer to is a complete
waste of time
Marvel really dropped the ball with this
it would be like watching the Justice
League from Alfred's perspective and it
made it really difficult to engage with
the characters we should care about I
want to give the right as a sidekick in
the balls
reason two boring villains I don't want
this to come across as disrespectful
Sigourney Weaver is one of the greatest
actresses as far as cinema is concerned
alien is undoubtedly a classic she
wasn't even bad in alien 3 in that film
is terrible however when all three
characters required to do is to stand in
a room or sit at a restaurant table
there's very little she can do with it I
really wanted to see the fear of death
driving her to fight no matter what but
spoiler alert she goes out like a punk
stabbed in the back she's written out in
episode 6 and the rest of her evil team
don't possess the charisma that she does
especially not in a finale kilgrave
kingpin and Diamondback were all
incredible villains these brutal leaders
were intimidating every time they
appeared on screen so it's a shame that
the magic couldn't be recaptured in the
defenders we are left with the old we
are not so different you and I speech
about ten times and everything just
feels completely toned down to this
gritty universe that Netflix Marvel
originally was where was that moment
that kingpin liked slam the guy's head
in the door where was the moment where
kilgrave killed his parents villains and
the defenders just didn't have moments
like this to really elevate them to that
level of threat and it's hard to invest
in them because of it and it just makes
them completely lackluster reason one
too many episodes my biggest complaint
about the defenders is that the plot is
stretched far too thin the main plot
points could have easily been covered in
a two-hour film so I have no idea why
they needed to be dragged out to eight
electro gets brought back to life by the
heart the heroes team up they stop the
villain that's the entire part of the
show so if baffling that it was dragged
out for longer than a Gareth gates
wedding speech in addition to this we
get more endings than The Return of the
King and by the 17th one I just wanted
to cancel my Netflix subscription and
buy some cyanide instead who has eight
hours to kill when it's this boring I
prefer real TV shows that don't use
padding or dry
hot lines just to make more revenue for
the show and that's why I like to watch
The Walking Dead anyway so that's my
list and why the defenders was really
disappointing do you agree with my main
problems with there so anything else I
should have included in this list am I
completely wrong about the defenders and
was it the best show of all time
better than Game of Thrones better than
Breaking Bad comment below let us know
and subscribe my channel if you like
this video as I do loads of comic movie
game reviews everything so if you know
that sort of stuff
please subscribe by clicking my face
somewhere around here you are thanks a
lot take care